- On this episode, these
two YouTube legends stop by.
(hip hop music)
- [Gary] You ask questions,
and I answer them.
This is The #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody,
this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and it's episode 247
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
First of all, what
do you got, Instagram?
That's Facebook live?
- [Dunk] Instagram Live.
- You're Facebook live?
And Facebook live is where
we're taking the
phone numbers from?
All right, Facebook live,
put your phone numbers down,
I'm gonna introduce
my guests in a second,
but your phone numbers in
and we're gonna
call you in a little bit.
We are on a roll with guests
on The #AskGaryVee Show,
last couple have been
really substantially awesome,
and this one, I think,
has the potential
to top it even more.
I've a cut in half
wrestling belt that,
if you watch DailyVee,
you know what that's about,
but for the ones that don't
or didn't
serendipitously catch that,
I'm gonna allow
these two tremendously
handsome individuals
introduce themselves,
so let's start with the better
looking one first, my man?
Why don't you tell the
Vayner Nation who you are.
- I am Lincoln
from What's Inside,
our channel is that
we cut stuff open, so.
- That's what you do?
- Yeah, that's
why we have there.
- And Lincoln, how old are
you and where are you from?
- I'm 11, and I'm
from Kingsville, Utah.
- So, you were born in 2006?
- Yes.
- (laughs) I know,
seriously, right?
- Bro, that hurts.
- Yeah.
- And you, my man?
- So, I'm Dan,
I am Lincoln's dad,
and we started this channel
off of his second
grade science project,
and all of a sudden it
turned into a YouTube channel
where we now have
four million subscribers.
I used to sell drugs,
like Viagra and Lipitor
and those things, and
now I'm a YouTuber full time,
as of July of this last year,
so kinda crazy the way
the digital world works.
- And I heard this story,
and I don't
think it made our vlog,
but the second grade project,
let's spend a second
on that because I think
it's important for
everybody to realize
what the seed of
things that can happen.
So many of you
are sitting at home
and saying I'm gonna
become an influencer,
I'm gonna become a YouTuber,
and you're
manipulating it in your head,
and you're trying to force
something instead of listening,
you're talking, right?
You're trying to manifest it
instead of paying attention to,
and reacting to something.
Yours was a reaction, you
became a full time YouTuber
by reacting to
something that happened,
let's tell that story,
because I think
it can be a framework
for so many of
you that can help you
get to what you want in reverse.
- Right, so, yeah, I mean we'd
had like 80 different videos
on YouTube that are family
videos and different things,
and I'd kind of
looked at the algorithm
and saw maybe we
should optimize these,
and you can make money
off of YouTube and stuff.
- How did you even
stumble in that thought,
did you read an article?
- So, way back in the day,
just reading articles and
seeing the Google Adsense,
I had a website
of a failed company
that I did way back in
the day that was like secret,
that people didn't know about,
some people
still don't know about.
We spent like $25,000
on this company, failed,
and I learned
about Google Adsense
with that website that we had,
and then once we
got onto YouTube,
I'm like oh, ads
can run on there.
- They have it here too.
- Yeah, and so he had a science
project, and at the time,
there was an article that
said that the number one place
that people look for
questions is on YouTube,
not Google.com but on YouTube,
and so his science project
was ask a
science related question,
and then you
answer it in your project.
So, his was Dad,
what's inside of sports balls?
So, we cut open the
five different sports balls,
I set my phone up
on the kitchen counter,
Lincoln was totally
sick during those videos.
- Yeah, like I was like a
zombie, I looked like a zombie.
- But we put
'em up there as like
we put 'em individual videos,
like what's inside a baseball?
- What? You were green?
- Not that much of a zombie.
- Got it, got it. Got it.
- And so we put
those on YouTube,
and we just like a year later,
we made four dollars
in one day off of Adsense.
- That's when you decided
to retire and go full time.
- That's it, full time, there
we go, quit the day job.
Yeah, so that was
December of 2014, and bam,
four dollars in one day.
So, I'm like Lincoln, I
think we got something here.
By the time you're 18 years old,
you might have a little
bit of money for college,
so let's just keep
cutting stuff open,
we'll keep doing it in
different worlds of YouTube.
And so, any time
somebody's watching a video,
the suggested will
hopefully be our video.
- So, we just cut open
some more sports balls,
and we published like
five videos in one day,
and we lost half
of our 40 subscribers.
- You went from 40 to 20?
- Exactly.
- You said okay, no more
posting five things a day.
- Yes, time to learn about like
what the
algorithm actually does.
So, January 2015, started fresh,
April of 2015 we
hit 1,000 subscribers,
we went out for ice cream,
we were super stoked.
- What flavor did you get?
- Oreo and vanilla.
- And you?
- I just got a
mixture of like cake batter
and yummy stuff, yeah.
- DRock, what's
your favorite ice cream?
- [DRock] Cookie dough.
- Andy?
- Good choice.
- Cookie dough's pretty
good, I vote cookie dough.
- [Gary] Cookie dough? Yeah,
I get it, I get it. Dunk?
- [Dunk] For
Ben &amp; Jerry, it's...
- No, not Ben &amp; Jerry, I
know that you've gone there,
globally, your
favorite ice cream flavor.
- [Dunk] Chocolate
fudge brownie.
- Just?
- [Justin] Cookies
and cream, for sure.
- Yeah, there we go.
- Cookies and cream?
Cookies and cream?
- [Man] Vanilla fudge.
- Gary?
- I mean, none of my
top three even made it,
coffee, mint chocolate chip,
and strawberry.
- Okay, that's good, nice.
- All right, good.
- I love strawberry.
- The fruit?
- No, for smoothies.
- Smoothies, okay, got it.
So, you made
1,000 bucks, now what?
- Well, we hit 1,000
subscribers in April,
and then by August
we hit 100,000, crazy.
- So, what was
the first viral video?
- So, the first viral video,
I would say would be the
bowling ball video that we had,
what's inside of a bowling ball,
and it's the first time I had
ever used a chop saw before,
and that was kind of the draw.
- If you go back
and watch that video,
he has a big ply
two by four stick
poking the bowling
ball trying to cut it open.
- It was bad.
- You guys have become much
better at cutting things open.
- Kind of.
(group laughter)
- A little bit better.
So yeah, a year later we
hit a million subscribers.
So December 2015--
- Wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
- Yes?
- Is today Wednesday?
- [DRock] Yes.
- Is it?
- So, he just misses school?
- He misses school today, yep.
But that's the thing.
We told him he's
learning from you.
Like, what?
- Yeah!
- You don't
learn this in school.
You don't get to be with the
king of digital advertising.
- No, no.
Just so you know.
Just so you know,
I didn't do that for a laugh.
I did that to
remind everybody how much
I actually believe
in what you're doing.
I promise you, this man
has no prayer of remembering
what the curriculum was
in his school on today's day,
but he will always
remember meeting DRock.
- That's right.
- For a second time!
(group laughter)
All right,
let's keep this going.
So, boom, 100,000.
Now you clearly didn't
say this to me the other day,
and now I'm putting
the pieces together.
You have been
historically fascinated by
this ad arbitrage,
this AdSense thing.
I, listen, I will
tell you that me and AJ
early on were
fascinated by Google Adwords
and AdSense and the arbitrage.
So you naturally went into
understanding distribution.
Right? You figured out
what your creative was,
which is, which is
by the way brilliant.
Because you never,
in your lifetime,
and you're a young dude,
will ever be able to cut
open every item on Earth.
Which is why Wine Library TV
was very successful.
And this is the
lesson for everybody.
When you create something,
try to create something
that you'll never
achieve doing all of it.
Too many people start channels
or concepts or creatives
that after four
videos, it's over.
Because you
can't do anything else.
Wine Library TV was amazing
because I could
never taste every wine.
- Makes sense.
- Forever.
You have no
chance of ever cutting.
So once you've got
your creative down,
you really got super
smart around distribution.
As a matter of fact,
as everybody knows,
I asked you,
once I picked up on that,
I emailed you a
couple days ago and said,
hey, can you
stay for an extra hour
and talk to Andy and the team?
Love to pick up on
some of your nuances.
And we know what we're doing,
but YouTube has never
been historically the place
I went quadruple deep down on.
And so you really became not
only this creative powerhouse
but you've become quite strong
at the distribution of
content within the ecosystem.
- Yeah, I think most of
it is we're not living--
- Are you proud
of your dad for that?
- Yeah.
- Okay, good.
- We're not the best actors
if you're going
to put it that way.
Like, a lot of times, we
don't even know what's going
to be inside of
something before we cut it open.
Because--
- Sometimes, I don't even
know what we're cutting open.
He just surprises me sometimes.
And I have no idea.
- Let's not downplay
what kind of star this guy is.
- Yeah. No, he's good.
He's good.
- You?
- No, I'm not
that great on an actor.
But I feel like we
understand the algorithm.
I have a finance background,
and that's what I did.
I'm like, I'm gonna
go and figure out
every little thing about
the algorithm that I can.
So that I can understand it.
- And it's a
moving target, right?
- It does.
It changes all the time.
- Right. Do you get
excited when it changes,
because you can find new things?
- Yeah, it's--
- Or, are you at
this big place now,
where you're like
do not change that much
because I've got it figured out?
- I mean, we do have it,
a lot of things figured out.
But as soon as
something does change,
we're pretty quick to
figure out what happened.
- And have you
brought him to that part?
Or is that kind of like it gets,
I mean, that's
kind of nerdy stuff.
- So, a lot of it is like,
I don't want
Lincoln to feel like
he's this kid that has a job.
Like, a full time job.
So, he comes and
does the fun stuff.
It is a lot of work.
- Yeah.
- But there are
some things that he --
- Yeah. I do have fun
with some of the ideas.
- Yeah, like creation.
Or when we're
working with a brand,
we'll come to
Lincoln and be like.
Sometimes I've
pitched something.
One of our first big possible
brand deals that we had,
a company came to us and
wanted to give us $50,000
and I was like, oh my
gosh, this is so much money.
I said, Lincoln,
all we have to do
is cut open this product.
And we can't say what it is.
So we didn't end up doing it.
I was like, this is so much
money, let's do it, Lincoln.
- Lincoln said no?
- He says, Dad,
we'll be selling out.
We can't do that product.
So what did we do that week?
- Lincoln, what gave
you the internal strength
to turn down so much money?
- I just didn't feel like
it was the right thing to do.
Because we kept on filming
things that are not brand deals.
'Cause we just
wanted to build it up, too.
- Yep. You thought Dad
was trying to cash out
a hair too early?
- Mhmmm.
- Very good.
- [Dan] Yeah. And the funny
thing is, this is a true story.
That week is the week
that we published a video
that I didn't like at all.
It was the what's
inside a rattlesnake rattle?
That video got 42
million views in a week.
And was the number
three most trending video
viral video of all
of 2016 on YouTube.
And that was the
week when I wanted to do
the $50,000 brand
deal that would have been
the sellout that Lincoln's like,
"No Dad, we can't do this."
- So Lincoln, do you take full
credit for all the success?
- Ahh, not really.
- What percentage
of the success is you,
and what percentage is Dad?
Just in your opinion,
one man's point of view?
- I think that 25% is me.
And, yeah.
- What a great kid, huh?
- He's the face, man.
People love Lincoln.
(laughter)
- Lincoln, Lincoln.
What we know, and what
everybody who's watching knows,
is that that for kids
age five and a half to eighteen
and beyond
YouTube is such an
incredibly important place.
You are the face
or one of the two faces
of a channel that has
four million subscribers.
Do your classmates
think you're famous?
- They don't think much of it.
But sometimes we just
watch the videos in class.
Like last year, we
watched a couple of them.
'Cause that's like around
subject that we're working on.
But really it's not that much
'cause, like, people at
school, like at recess,
they say, I love your video.
Let's go play football,
let's go play basketball, let's
go--
- They don't make
a big deal about it.
- Yeah.
- Cause you keep it chill.
- Okay, but how 'bout when
you guys go to ice cream now?
I have to assume sometimes
people roll up on you and say,
whoa, I love your videos!
- Yeah.
- And people want to
take selfies with you.
- Yeah, that's cool.
- You love that.
- Yeah.
- I agree.
- I love that.
(group laughter)
- I agree.
Okay so, so,
what's the punchline now?
Like, this is insanity.
- It's a good question.
Like we, after
watching some of your videos,
we want to try to grow in
some of our other platforms.
YouTube, I feel
like we're crushing it
and we're having a blast.
But maybe on Instagram.
Lincoln's favorite
platform right now,
not favorite platform
but favorite thing to do
is to go live on
Instagram right now.
- I just love connecting
with fans in Instagram live.
I don't know why,
but I just love it.
- 'Cause it's addicting.
- Yeah!
- Yeah.
- Yeah, you just have
conversation with them.
So we're
learning that side of it.
We're building a brand.
We've, we've worked with
more brands this year already
than we worked with
our entire history so far.
So, luckily, like we
had some good mentors
like Shonduras with Snapchat.
He took us under
his wing and was like,
hey, help me grow
my YouTube channel
I'll teach you how to not
stop making TV commercials
in your YouTube
videos, but actually make
authentic integrations that make
the brand look like the all-star
and makes great
content for your fans.
So, so, yeah.
We're still
learning and evolving.
It's just like,
just us right now.
We haven't even hired
a full time employee yet.
- Let's go to the phone.
But that's coming.
- Soon. In the
next couple weeks,
we've got two
people coming on board.
- Two full?
- Two full time employees.
- How many people applied?
- A lot.
(laughter)
A lot of people.
Yeah.
- Mhmmm.
- In person,
weeded out a lot of people.
- One of the
things I keep telling you
is to document and not create.
When you document,
or you just do,
serendipity happens and
then you can react to it.
And that's the story of this.
- [Brian] Hello?
- Hey, this is GaryVee
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Brian] That's fucking sick!
- (laughter) Yes it is.
- [Brian] Awesome!
- What's your name?
- [Brian] My name
is Brian Pickowitz.
- Hey, Brian.
So what's your question?
- [Brian] So right now I own an
online personal
training company,
where I do online coaching.
And I have a really
successful platform that I'm
operating on
Facebook and Instagram,
but I'm having a
really difficult time
getting more
viewership and subscriptions
through my YouTube channel.
So I don't think
it's as much of a problem
with the content,
although the content
could certainly be better.
But I guess
I really don't understand,
is there something else
I could be putting into it,
that would help
really drive more content
to my YouTube channel?
- Good question,
really good question.
How much time are you
putting into your titles
and your descriptions?
And from that side of the thing,
are you paying much
attention to the tags
and titles of
descriptions that you put in?
- [Brian] I am paying
more attention now to the tags,
as I've gotten more into it.
I try not to
clickbait people too much,
but at the same time,
that is a big part of
getting attention organically.
I kind of base off
of doing a Monday rant,
like a Monday motivational rant,
and then I do vlogs
throughout the week.
So I'm trying to
build a brand around that.
I'm trying to attach
it to different fitness
entrepreneurs and
things of the like,
but I guess I don't understand
more of how that works.
- Before we get
into the smart questions,
let me ask you a macro question.
What are you trying to achieve?
- [Brian] So, right now
I honestly deleted
you for a while,
which is awesome.
I kind of added you again,
based off of just
trying to get more focus on it.
For me, I have personal goals--
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
You deleted me
because of my rants of like,
stop listening to me and go do?
- [Brian] Yes.
- Or you deleted me,
Okay, that reason, right?
- [Brian] Yes.
But what I
started tapping into again
was just trying to
get more direction.
But to answer your question,
I am a budding
competitive bodybuilder,
so I'm working my way on that.
And I'm building
this coaching business
as I grow.
So my goal is,
as I grow,
my personal brand grows,
and this coaching grows with it.
So I want to attach different--
(crosstalk)
Yeah.
What are you coaching?
And what does it cost,
and what does it do?
- [Brian] Well, what I offer is,
essentially, lifestyle coaching.
I am a competitive bodybuilder,
but I don't look at what I do as
a way of offering
people bodybuilding,
because that's
not what I wanna do.
I want to teach
people how to diet healthy,
understand how to diet--
- And how much does that cost?
- [Brian] It depends on the
package that they buy.
Some of my
packages range up into...
I have a year-long package
that's about $3000.
And it kind of
goes down from there.
The actual product
is very in-depth, I guess,
as far as what I'm
offering my clients,
because the way
that I look at it is,
I'm not just giving
you a product of value,
based on this and that.
I'm someone
who's in your corner,
so I try to
actually build a team
based off me and my
client that makes it so
that they know that.
I think the
hardest thing about fitness
and getting in
shape and stuff like that,
is most people
feel like they're alone.
- And do you do
that in actuality?
In phone calls and video?
Or is that
through content email?
- [Brian] It is
through phone calls.
- How often?
- [Brian] Biweekly and then they
have weekly report cards
that they have to fill out.
The business is actually very
successful at this point.
I've worked with over 200
clients in two years.
And the hard
part right now, I guess, is
I'm trying to kind of transition
into more of growing my brand,
rather than just
growing based off clients.
If that makes sense.
- Of course.
- [Brian] My
YouTube channel is where
I'm trying to put
more of my energy,
so I can attach
because not everyone can afford
an expensive
online coaching package.
So I want to branch
into smaller products
that make it so
I can grow this message
a lot more vastly, I guess.
- Have you
factored in that you're
one of 8 million people that are
trying to do the
same exact blueprint?
- [Brian] Yes.
- Okay.
So let's go back to
the YouTube channel,
because I'm done
with my macro work.
- He said clickbaiting.
I think he put a negative
connotation on something
that you've used to
create an enormous opportunity.
- Yeah, I don't consider it
clickbait if it's something
that's within your video,
like for example our
rattlesnake rattle video,
the one part where
you see the thumbnail,
it's a black background
and then we have
the rattle on top of it.
That was planned out,
I was going to
use a cutting board.
I wasn't going
to cut it on there,
but we purposely, in the video
went, oh this is too hard,
let's get a cutting board,
but it was just for that shot,
just for the thumbnail,
it was thought out.
So, that's in the thumbnail
and then the
title is like what's
inside a rattlesnake rattle.
We have a family channel where
we will do clickbaity stuff,
but if it's in the
video that's what it's about
and that's going to be...
- No, no, no, no, no,
let's just
establish this right now.
Here's clickbait,
naked boobs inside
and it's a football video.
Watch this video,
win a $1,000,000
and it's an ice cream video.
It's not being smart.
We are terrible at
our YouTube titling.
Me and DRock debate over a text
and I'm like, uh,
uh, rumbling in Arizona.
We do nothing smart
about our image thumbnail
and our title,
which is why I'm just
winning on the actual content,
not on all the smart things
and I know that because
where I do the smart things,
I win and I win twice,
10, 15 times better
than when I
actually know the de...
What I'm doing on YouTube,
which is my whole career,
has been
lollygagging on YouTube,
including leaving YouTube
when I was one of
the first YouTube stars
and going to Viddler.
So, it's this funny
relationship I have with it,
but I want to
make sure you, Brian
and everybody knows
that clickbaiting is
when you fully
trick somebody into it.
- For sure.
- Not you describe it properly
and make it
enticing to watch it.
Clickbaiting is putting, again,
an attractive
individual on the image
and when you click into it,
it had nothing to do with it
and that one
second they flashed that,
so they could show that.
- Exactly.
- Not strategically
thinking about
what you're going
to make in the video
and then doing
that for that purpose
that's called being smart.
- Yep.
And, and a lot...
- [Brian] Absolutely,
absolutely.
- Listen man,
I'll tell you this,
I answered your
question just so you know.
Which is everybody's
trying to do what you're doing.
People want to sell
courses then they realize that,
that doesn't only scale so much
so then what they decide is
let me get even more famous
so I can sell
t-shirts or get paid $500,000
to write a book or
get $100,000 to speak.
Here's the good news,
you can do it,
it's going to come
down to how good you are
because what I
know that you know
that everybody
knows is, you know,
you're getting paid for
the access of the phone call
and the curation of the content
because the content is free.
They can go find that
stuff, there's the tried
and true principles of lifestyle
and health and benefits.
They're established.
I think what you
need to think about is
how you disproportionally,
disproportionally bring value
to your audience.
The reason I wrote the Thank You
Economy after Crush It!
This is where you
turn to the books.
Ty, thank you.
The reason I wrote Thank You
Economy after Crush It! was,
Crush It! was, hey
everybody can do this.
Thank You Economy is, oh crap,
everybody's going to do this,
let me help people
figure out how to win
in a world where it's
going to be very competitive.
Bro, I'm telling
you something right now.
Every word out of your mouth
was, what's in it for you.
If you switch it into
what's in it for them,
you will have a chance.
- [Brian] Mhmmm.
- Period.
- [Brian] No,
absolutely, absolutely.
- I promise you if I go
onto your Instagram account
right now that
there's comments on your posts
and I promise you
didn't reply to all of them.
- [Brian] That's not true.
You check it out.
- I will.
I want you to.
- I'm doing it right now.
- What's your Instagram handle?
- [Brian] Brian Pickowitz.
P-I-C-K-O-W-I-T-Z.
- Bri, is it one word,
or space, or Brian?
- [Brian] Yeah, just one word,
just one word.
- Brian P-I.
- [Brian] C-K-O-W-I-T-Z.
- Yep, I see it.
Dude you're in good shape.
- [Brian] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- [Brian] Thank you,
this is my life (laughs).
- Alright, good job.
One thing I wasn't anticipating
was three comments (laughs).
(group laughter)
Dude.
Yeah, okay, so what's awesome,
first of all, is I'm pumped
that that's your mentality.
The problem is...
So, first of all,
kudos to Brian.
He's absolutely right
that he is getting in there
and engaging.
So, first of all, I'm
fucking pumped with you.
Sorry.
(Brian laughing)
The thing that does concern
me is the stunning low amount
of comments off your 4,000 base.
Did you build that organically
or have you ever done anything
that made it go to 4,000 like
a contest or something random?
Tell me.
- [Brian] I've never
bought any, quietly entertained
and the like...
I've pretty much have been
building this
the last two years.
So, very organic.
I do try to reach
out to my audience.
Asking more questions and
trying to get more feedback.
I find that, that usually
comes through DM's though.
- Yeah, I agree. I agree.
- [Brian] Not necessarily.
Most people, I get...
With what I do it's
so hard for some people
to want to ask for advice.
So, I find that a lot of times
what I get is the
private message on the side
and obviously, that's where
it helps to put in the work.
I get putting it
on the other aspect
of putting it out in the
open is a little bit hard.
- Yeah, and as far as
the YouTube front goes
I would just say if you
want to crush it on YouTube
all the information is
out there. Go to Google,
type in YouTube,
click on the news,
find out what
the latest news is.
Type in YouTube SEO.
Really hone in your
titles and descriptions.
Do things that are timely.
Caption your videos
because YouTube doesn't
really care as much
about the tags anymore
like they used to.
They do really care
about your actual captions
and what's said in the video.
If we're doing a
video about boxing,
I'm going to mention
Floyd Mayweather, Manny Pacquiao
when I'm talking
about a punching bag
because I know that it's going
to be picked up in the captions
and then hopefully
that will be picked up
in the suggested views
if somebody's watching
a Manny Pacquiao video.
So, I would do that.
Think about your timing, try
to find a regular schedule.
YouTube loves regular schedules.
- He said
something very important.
Listen, he said be timely.
That means hack culture, right?
You're talking about
lifestyle, fitness, health.
You got to be smart
being aggressive when
Arnold Schwarzenegger
is in the news.
When something is
happening in fitness.
When the competitions are on
ESPN, World's Strongest Men.
Be smart about
what's going on in culture.
- [Brian] Okay.
- Alright buddy.
- [Brian] That helps
out a lot actually.
- Alright, good luck.
Good stuff.
- Yeah.
Alright, let's keep it going.
So Linc, while we're
getting the next phone call,
what's the most
exciting thing that has happened
because of this whole process?
- I've love traveling,
I've love seeing new places
and exploring. That's
something I've love to do
and is so much fun.
- So I know that when we were
hanging out the last time,
you went to Paris for
example for like 20 hours.
(phone ringing)
- Yeah.
- That was the coolest.
- Yeah that was so much fun!
I just love traveling.
- I get it I mean,
that's it you love it.
- Yeah. Love it.
- [Ari] Hello?
- Hello this is GaryVee
on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Ari] Oh my
gosh that's awesome, hi!
- Hi what's your name
and we are you from?
- [Ari] Hi my name
is Ari Cobb and I am from
New Orleans, Louisiana.
- Have you been to New Orleans?
- No.
- Sounds like dad
we need to make a trip.
- I've never been there either.
- Alright so
what's your question?
- [Ari] Oh my god I can't
believe this is happening.
Okay my question is
I wanted to know since
you're all about inspiration
and everything,
I've been feeling a little bit
unmotivated and
I've been feeling like
I should be doing something
or I should be,
just I feel like
I should be pulled in like,
I'm feeling uninspired
basically that's my question
how do you get,
when you lose inspiration
or you lost motivation
how do you get it back?
- I get it back by remembering
that you might die tomorrow.
- [Ari] That's true.
- So I'm inspired
by practicality and reality
and the truth which is
it is ridiculously impossible
to become a human being.
I am one, I have other
good things going for me
as a human being
and I'm just grateful.
You're dwelling and
looking at what you don't have
versus looking at what you have.
If you actually
looked at what you had,
your health,
you know, living in America
who the heck knows
what would be on your list
if you actually spent all your
time looking at that versus
I don't have a million
dollars, I'm not famous,
I don't have this,
if you spent all your time
on what you have
versus what you don't have
you would be the
happiest girl on Earth.
- [Ari] I didn't
think about it like that.
- I'm aware that's
why you're uninspired.
(Ari laughs)
You know, that's
what's happening.
You're spending clearly
and you're
dragging yourself down
into what you don't have right?
- [Ari] Yeah.
- You've been spending your--
How do you
- Go ahead.
- [Ari] How do you
just, like when you're
I doubt that you
ever feel negative
'cause you
appreciate everything just
how do you just,
I feel so negative all the time
and like you said I do always
dwell on what I don't have
and just
everything that's going wrong
how do you stay
positive and motivated?
- Lincoln how do you stay
so positive I'll get to that
in a second but I wanna
incorporate my guests here.
And you're a young man
you haven't lived that long.
- (laughs) Yeah
- But when you're
down what do you do?
- (Sigh).
- Do you ever get down?
- Sometimes yeah.
- Okay.
- I just see what I
could be doing right now
instead of just
looking at it
and just being sad about that
instead of looking forward
to how to fix it.
- Dad?
- That's good I think for me
I was born in the Philippines,
really, really poor place
I lived there for two years
when I was 19 years old
and I feel like that
side of it is something that,
it's interesting because I go
to the Philippines whenever
we go back, we went
back there a couple years ago
I see how poor people are but
yet they're like the happiest
people in the world and I'm
like how is that possible?
But then when I come back to
America--
- 'Cause money
doesn't buy happiness
- Yeah but then it's
interesting--
- Money doesn't buy happiness
- You forget too you
know even though I was born
in those poor circumstances
I come after being in America
for a year you get
caught up in all those things
and it, I think coming
back to that whatever it is
that grounds you
whether it's your family,
getting out
there and just working
or serving other people being
thankful for what you have
like whatever it is that
grounds you if you can get
back to that point and
feel grateful and thankful
and cut those things out
your life that you don't need
that helps you bring happiness.
- Ari how old are you and
what are the top three things
that are bringing you down?
- [Ari] I'm 20 years old.
- Two, zero.
- [Ari] Yes.
- Okay, and so what's
making you Debbie Downer?
- [Ari] I'm in school
right now and I'm down just
because I'm just
stressed out because I feel that
when I get out of
school I'm not going to have
anything to do,
I'm down because when I train
I'm not as good
as I would like to be
and
it's mainly
just being negative
and being too hard on myself.
- Right and so do you think
that stems from the
way you were parented?
- [Ari] Yes and no, I was
really sheltered as a kid,
in kind of like, my
mom treated me like I was
a special little snowflake,
which is not the case anymore.
- Or maybe you are, in
just a different way that
your mom then created it, right?
Like, in theory,
everybody makes fun
of the modern parenting,
and everybody makes
their kids feel
like they're the best,
and now the kids are saying,
"Oh crap, I was confused,
I thought I was the best,"
but the reality is we have
to take on the responsibility
of ourselves, like my
mom told me I was the best,
I equally spent
all my time thinking
that I was not the best,
because I could understand
that I wasn't winning in
every single thing always.
You know what I mean?
I mean,
- [Ari] Yeah.
- She might've
created that sheltered thing,
but I promise you,
you realize pretty quickly
in first, second,
fourth, ninth grade,
there was things that you
weren't the best at, right?
- [Ari] True, very true.
- Whose opinion
are you worried about?
- [Ari] I'm worried
about the opinion of
the people that I train with,
the people that have
invested so much time in me.
- And what are we talking
about training-wise?
In what?
- [Ari] I'm an Olympic lifter
and I do mixed martial arts.
- Woah.
- Wow. Okay.
- [Ari] And I, oh I'm sorry.
- No, go ahead, what
does "an Olympic lifter" mean?
Like, you might go to the
Olympics, or you're in it?
Explain that to me.
- [Ari] Oh, God, no I wish.
- Got it.
- [Ari] Olympic lifting is the
snatch and the clean and jerk
and it's different movements
that you do with the barbell.
- So what, can you
please tell me this, Ari?
You literally go
into your room sometimes,
like after a workout, and say,
"Damn it, I wish I
lifted 10 more pounds"?
- [Ari] That, and
it's just, I feel like
I could've tried harder,
that I could've done more,
that I could've
had a better attitude.
- Ari, did you see the
video that I posted on YouTube
that says 'you need
to be your biggest fan'?
- [Ari] Yes.
- You need to watch that
eight thousand times in a row.
- [Ari] Okay.
- Listen, Ari let me give you
a really good piece of advice.
The rest of the world is gonna
critique you and judge you.
You need to stop
doing that for yourself.
- [Ari] Okay.
- I'm being dead
serious with you.
- I think the other
side is just this day and age
in social media, a lot of
people, even with our videos,
they see the video,
they see us traveling,
they see the
glamorous side of things,
but then maybe they
don't see the other side,
where it's just,
we're regular people,
like there's no difference
between the way we live
than any other people live,
like we have our down times.
Sometimes we're sad,
sometimes things can be hard,
but I think it's important
to not compare ourselves
to other people on
social media and see
all the glamorous stuff.
- Are you envious
of what you're seeing on social?
- [Ari] Yes, I'm very envious
and that's a big problem.
I'm a very envious person.
- Ari, I'm not
envious of anybody.
You need to figure
out how to really become
a bigger fan of yourself,
and not be...
Listen, if you're
aware of these things,
and I don't know if
it's going to see somebody,
I don't know if
there's a system in place,
but you're not
gonna win this game
if you continue down this path.
- [Ari] Yeah, I know
I'm not. I'm just gonna,
self-loathing is not
gonna get me anywhere,
I just don't know how to fix it.
- Yeah. I respect that, and
like, I'm not a psychiatrist
or you know, I just
wanna get these things outta
your mouth
because I think they help,
but you've gotta
realize you got it so good.
(grunts)
There's seven point seven
billion people on this Earth.
Ari, you rank in
the top percentile
just be being in New Orleans.
- She's Olympic lifting.
I can't, I'm too skinny,
I can't even do that.
(laughing)
- She doesn't have
a disease currently, like,
Ari you really gotta get
your perspective in order.
- [Andy] Break the pattern.
- You gotta break the pattern.
That's exactly right.
- Ari, you have it awesome.
- [Ari] Yeah.
- I mean it.
You just need to believe it now.
- [Ari] Yeah. I'm
gonna work on that.
- I have good news for
you, you live in New Orleans.
There's some shitty
neighborhoods. Go take a ride.
- [Ari] That is true.
- Wake the fuck up.
- [Ari] There's some
shit down here.
- Wake the fuck up.
The majority of people
have it worse than you.
Sorry.
- [Ari] Yeah.
- Yeah. I need a
more emphatic "yeah".
- [Ari] Yeah! You're right.
- And that's it.
- [Ari] I'm
writing all this down.
- I have a news
alert by the way.
Nobody cares about
your problems either.
- [Ari] Yeah.
- Like, too many people think
their dwelling and complaining
leads to an action,
because they grew up
in environments where it did.
Problem is, mom's
not around anymore.
- [Ari] We all got shit, man.
- We all got shit.
- [Ari] We all got shit.
- Yep.
So, I'm telling you: the
number one thing that I do
when I get dangerously,
and I'm never there,
but I fix my perspective.
Get in your car
right now, and go drive
around parts of New Orleans.
You could wake up real
fast, if you choose to.
- [Ari] Okay.
- Good.
- [Ari] You're absolutely right.
- Oh, that I know.
I'm just sitting here,
and keeping you on the phone,
(Ari laughing)
'cause I'm trying
to think of a way
to get you to know.
You know?
- [Ari] Yeah.
- Good luck, update us, okay?
- [Ari] Thank you.
- You're welcome.
- What do you think?
- It's a tough one,
'cause she has to believe
withinin herself, and
not compare herself
- And this is a common theme,
- to other people, and it's,
it is.
- where there was a vibe there
not so different than Taylor's,
that we had the other day.
This whole, like,
"Other people have it better,
"I don't have it as good," like,
it's just not real, and
people are allowing themselves
to go down this
rabbit hole, and you know,
you were super happy
when you weren't making,
people were saying, "oh,
it's easy for him to say,
"he's getting $50,000 brand deals",
but you were
happy when you weren't!
- Right, right.
- Like, it's not a money thing.
It's a mindset thing.
And you gotta figure out
how to break that pattern.
- Yeah. It doesn't matter
how rich or how poor you are.
You gotta find
that within yourself,
(phone ringing)
what makes you happy.
- [Andy] Swardik.
- But, I'm glad
she's willing to ask.
That's a good step.
(phone ringing)
- Well, the reason
I'm keeping people on
is the fact that people
are even saying it out loud,
because 99% don't.
- [Q] Hello?
- Hey, it's GaryVee,
and you're on
The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [Q] Holy shit.
Thank you so much.
Oh my God. Thank you,
thank you, thank you.
- You're welcome.
What's your name,
and where are you from?
- [Q] My name
is Swardic Mayanja.
I'm from Woburn, Massachusets.
Everyone calls me Q,
just like the letter.
- Alright, Q, I've got
a very important question.
- [Q] Please.
- Are you a Patriots fan?
- [Q] Oh, of
course I'm a Patriots fan.
I'm sorry.
(group laughter)
- Alright, Q,
I had to do it to you,
but I promise you that I will
call you back another time.
I'm just not in
the mood right now.
I'm still bitter.
Let's move on.
- Oh my gosh.
- Keep it going.
- Oh, don't ask
Lincoln any of that.
Kick us out now.
- Lincoln's a Patriots guy, too?
- There's one player
on there that he loves
that just maybe went
on there six months ago.
- Okay, he doesn't bother me.
- We're college guys, but yeah.
- That's fine.
- That's great.
Nope, not the other
guy you're thinking of.
(phone ringing)
- That's the guy.
I could have ended this meeting.
Hey it's GaryVee, and you're
on The #AskGaryVee Show.
- [David] Holy fucking
shit, are you serious?
- I am.
What's your name
and where you're from?
- [David] Yeah, this is
David Trotter from Jersey City.
Jersey love in the house, baby.
- Alright, David,
what's going on man?
What's your question?
And can you turn that
down in the background
because it's echoing.
- [David] Yeah, hold on.
I'm like driving in my car.
Let me just pull over.
- Yeah, pull over.
Because we don't need a death.
Yeah, go ahead.
- [David] Alright, so,
first off, Gary,
I came to see
you're whole company man.
You flew away.
You weren't even there.
I missed you.
- I'm sorry, man.
- [David] Brought
my whole house.
- I apologize.[
- [David] That's alright.
I'll see you again. All good.
Anyway, so I just partnered
into to a wine company.
I'm a 15% partner,
my fiance is the other 15%.
We have a 70% partner.
I think you actually did them
on Wine Library
way back in the day.
It's called David's Family Wine.
- Okay.
- [David] Formed
with Michelle Reeves.
- Yep.
- [David] I don't know
if you remember them.
- I remember them
- [David] So, it's
been great bottle of wine,
but the brand has kind of been
dead the past three years.
Michelle lived in New York,
moved over to the West Coast,
and had two kids and went
from doing $300,000 a year
down to $80,000 a year.
And, you know, I have
a hospitality company.
She roped me in
because we're doing events
all over New York, New Jersey,
and she's like look, I think
you'd be a great partner
to kind of reinvigorate it.
We're trying to figure
out what the next strategy is
for the company.
I tend to think it's a
couple of different angles,
like we have the idea,
obviously like distribution,
like we're in Gramercy Tavern,
we're in Eleven Madison Park.
Reinvigorating those sales.
The other angle
would be, obviously,
the direct to consumer angle
that we added to our website,
and then I kinda
had this crazy idea
like why don't we
screw all of this stuff
and go around it.
We do 500 cases a year,
why don't we just do a bunch
of really cool events,
and maybe the only way
that you can get the wine
is, you know,
through these events.
I tend to think the GaryVee
answer might be all of them.
So I wanted to throw that out
there and see what you said
you thought might
be a really good idea.
- This show's eventually
not going to be fun,
because I'm super
pissed that you took my answer.
(group laughter)
- [David] Sorry!
- I mean, look, not sorry.
It makes me happy.
It means that people
are hearing me, right?
The answer's all
of them, brother.
Now look, the
model of doing events
that it's the only way to buy it
would then
eliminate the other two.
I wouldn't go that hard.
I would just still do events,
but I would create as many...
Too many times
people don't understand
that you need to
create as many ways for people
to buy as possible, right?
They may discover
it at a restaurant.
They may walk
into the Wine Library
and buy it off the shelf.
They may go to a
party and taste it
and then go buy it.
You've gotta do
direct-to-consumer branding
on Instagram and Facebook for
your direct to consumer channel,
directly from the
winery because you get to keep
100% of the economics,
instead of sharing it with
the retailer and distributor.
So, there's a
million ways to do it.
It sounds like you're
pretty grounded in it.
I have a funny
feeling above and beyond
the answer I just gave you,
you know the next answer
which is it's just patience.
It sounds like you're grounded.
It's just a matter of time,
and you've gotta
think about the details.
I think one of the
great things that my partners
here on this episode have done,
is they talk about the nuances.
Here's a nuance,
be smarter about how you guys,
and what you put on
the label of the wine.
Is your social handles on
the back of the label, right?
Can you induce
people to share it
by doing a hashtag on
the back of the label.
So, it's some of
these nuances, as well,
but it sounds like
you've got the religion down,
which excites me
around the strategy.
- [David] Hey, man, listen--
- Hello?
Oh, he was about to say
something really cool about me.
(group laughter)
I took that one,
because I wasn't sure
that you were really ready
to give a detailed wine answer
at this point in your career.
- Yeah.
- You've drank no wine yet.
- No.
- Okay, understood.
(group laughter)
- [Andy] I saw
Swardic just comment
- Q?
- [Andy] Q. Please call me
in the next #AskGaryVee,
but I truly
respect your decision.
(group laughter)
- Let's call Q back.
I'm happy he said that.
Yeah, let's call him back.
- [Andy] He has a
question about YouTube.
- Good, let's do it.
(group laughter)
That's a good job by Q.
Q, way to handle that adversity.
Right?
He didn't dwell.
- Yep.
- He figured out how to fix it.
He did it buy
doing a public Tweet.
(phone ringing)
And, Q has won this episode
of The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Just like they win
the Super Bowl every year. Yep.
- [Q] Hello?
(laughing)
- Q!
- [Q] Yes.
- I respect what you did.
I like the way you
handled the adversity,
and so we're rewarding it.
You are now back, first
time ever, two-time caller,
on The #AskGaryVee Show,
and Lincoln's fired up!
- [Q] I truly,
truly respect that.
I do, I do.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
- What's your question?
- [Q] Oh my God.
So, I just started a
brand-new YouTube channel,
and it's like,
from the beginning,
it's super,
super, super difficult
just breaking and
making a name for yourself.
- As it should be.
- [Q] I wanna
know real talk though.
Yes, yes, as it should be.
But, I wanna
know, like real talk,
where should I go,
because I'm lucky enough
where people in my life,
people who surround me
are all really supportive,
but I need people
who are truly, truly real
at giving me critical, you
know, constructive criticism.
Just tell me what
I'm doing right, wrong.
Everyone's like oh,
that's cute, that's nice,
good for you, but I don't
know if it's actually good,
because I just know these people
so basically, like my mom,
telling me they
love me and it's good.
- When it comes to YouTube,
this is a really good question,
like we hear this a lot,
and if you look at our channel,
I didn't share that
we had a YouTube channel
with my co-workers,
my parents, with my family,
until we hit
100,000 subscribers,
and we were in the news.
- [Q] Holy shit.
- But we had a
bunch of different videos
that we tried different things.
We didn't think we'd
become these huge YouTubers,
but that's the kind
of bit of advice I have
is that what I see as a
big problem that people do
is that they will
go put a bunch of money
behind a YouTube channel,
and they will throw it out there
to all of their
Facebook friends and family,
and they'll go on a
give them artificial views,
and then they'll give
them these positive comments,
and then you start feeling
like oh this is a good idea,
but even if all of your Facebook
friends watched your video
every single day
for the entire week,
you're not gonna make
any money off the channel.
It's not going
to grow that much.
It really does take,
you have that global audience.
The beauty about not telling
everyone what you're doing
on your YouTube
channel until you find an idea,
like ours was
cutting stuff open,
that's what took,
but some of the other videos
we just made the videos private.
The beauty of that is
you have the whole world
that can look at your channel
and they can give you feedback,
and sometimes they're pretty,
they're always honest.
Like, they're brutally honest,
and that way you
don't live off of like
oh, my mom said it's good,
or my family said it's good.
You can find an idea,
and then finally
find out what works,
and what your
niche is on YouTube,
and then go all-in.
Hide everything else,
create a new brand,
and just go for it.
- [Q] So, just to
follow up on that.
So, now they know and
I can't go back on that.
- Yeah.
- [Q] Like I have
over 100 videos up,
and basically my channel is,
I interview people,
and it's called like
the Everyday Hero Series.
So, I interview
every day people, right?
And, I consider them heroes,
and they tell me
why they are a hero,
why they are special,
and that's my idea.
- How long have
you been doing it,
and what do your
numbers look like?
- [Q] So, my numbers
are pretty, pretty crappy.
I've been doing this
series of this type thing
for about two months now.
I have like,
probably 35 to 40 videos up,
of probably like 8 to
10 different interviews,
and I'll chop them up.
I'll put some on Instagram,
like a real short clip.
I'll put the
longer videos on Facebook.
- How many subscribers,
and how many
views are these getting?
- [Q] I average
anywhere between like 10
or 50 views and I have like
45 subscribers, I'm brand new.
Like I started six months ago.
- Okay, so what's,
why was the advice
that you were just
given not feasible?
- [Q] Come again?
Say that again please?
- So you just got some
great advice in my opinion,
and then you said, well yeah
but, the cat's out of the bag.
They already know.
Why did you dwell on
the fact that they know
versus the strategy of
trying different things?
- [Q] That's a good question.
And the thing is,
I'm not dwelling on it.
What I really do want
to go out and look for,
is am I not just
getting exposure?
Or does my idea suck?
I want someone to tell me.
- Sure. But I have good news.
Somebody told you.
It's called the market.
They told you it sucks so far.
- [Q] Okay, yes.
- But, but,
Wine Library TV was told two
months in that it sucked.
You were told, kind of sort
of, in the first couple months.
- It took a long time
til it actually took off.
But it, you do have
to listen to the market
and you have to look and see,
does this video have
the potential to go viral?
Are a lot of people
gonna be watching it?
And if you're already looking,
make sure your
looking at the algorithm,
the advice I gave earlier.
Make sure you're doing
all of those other things
that you can
control, like your titles.
The first line of the
description is super important.
Then some of your
tags not as important.
Make sure you're
captioning your videos.
But at some point you
want to look at it and say,
this stuff isn't taking off.
Is there something
else I can do?
And experiment with it, come
up with different thumbnails.
- Q, I think you
should start making videos
as the Boston guy
that hates the Patriots.
(group laughter)
Q, real quick, real quick, Q.
Why do you want to do this?
Like straight up.
- [Q] Come again?
- You want to become Casey?
You want to make
$5 million dollars a year
just making videos?
What are you doing?
You want to be Ted Koppel,
like why are we doing this?
- [Q] Sort of like,
I'm going to be honest.
- Hold on real quick,
real quick before
you answer that I
just had a thought.
Do you know who Ted Koppel is?
Yeah, okay.
Go ahead.
- [Q] Who?
- Yeah no, okay.
Sorry Q.
You don't either, I get it.
So why are you doing this?
- [Q] Because
I want to basically
be like the
male Ellen DeGeneres.
I want to be like Joe Rogan,
like the dream.
That's the dream.
- Great.
- [Q] Like that's what
I want to do.
- Great, if that's true,
then you need to
stop calling shows and
getting positive feedback or
feedback two months into it.
If you're trying to do that,
you need to know that you
are on a ridiculous marathon
and that most likely,
nothing good will happen
for the next seven to 11 years.
- [Q] Seven to 11?
- Yes sir.
- [Q] Okay, I mean
that's absolutely legit.
But then just a
little off topic,
I'm sorry for taking
up so much of your time.
- No problem. You're
not taking up my time.
I just need you
to know something.
- [Q] Yes.
- Whenever that
piece of advice comes out
and the response is,
"Yes your right, but,"
you've already lost.
You know that right?
- [Q] Wow, okay.
- That's the punchline, Q.
The punchline is,
it's seven to 11 years.
How old are you again?
- [Q] 23.
- Great.
I'm telling you to your face,
you have no prayer
of being Joe Rogan or
Ellen DeGeneres for
the most part.
And if you do, I want
to remind you that
both of them had
7 to 15 year careers
before they even looked
to remotely close to Ellen.
I just want to remind everyone
who's watching this show,
I have been in
the public limelight
producing content
on an everyday basis
for the last 11 years.
- [Q] Wow, okay.
So like my
perspective is just...
- Fucking broken.
You're worried
about shit two months in
on a journey that is gonna
be the next 10 to 15 years.
- [Q] Yeah.
- You're just not
in the right mindset.
- [Q] That's real.
- And you know
what else is real?
You haven't Googled,
how do I get better titles?
How do I use YouTube SEO.
So you've lost on
the architect side
and you're also
losing on the plumbing side.
I won on the architect side.
I don't know all your story,
but you clearly won
on the plumbing side.
And you're not playing either.
- [Q] Geez, lord. Okay.
- Alright?
- [Q] Alright.
- You know how you Patriot fans
make fun of shitty teams?
That's what I'm
doing to you in reverse.
This is how a Jets fan
feels good about himself.
(group laughter)
You know what, what I just did?
This is my favorite thing,
just a little side story.
I never tell this.
I'm such a bad human
being at sporting events.
I'm the worst
version of myself, Lincoln.
There's something
called beer muscles.
This is where people
get drunk drinking beer,
stupid guys that are older
and then they
want to fight people.
I have sports muscles.
When I go into a stadium
I actually want to fight people.
I'm like the reverse of me.
- [Q] My goodness.
- Yeah, so when
I go to Foxborough,
Q you're gonna love this.
When I got to Foxborough,
and I wear my Jets jersey
and people start
making fun of me.
I change the conversation,
literally this is me
arguing with a fan, but
the guys like, you suck.
Jets suck.
I go yeah, yeah bro.
But what about me versus you.
(Q laughs)
I'm like, tell
me about your life.
Beause I'm
beating you, dick face.
- [Q] You get real petty
when you go to Foxborough.
- I get real angry.
So listen man, your
macro and micro are broken.
Fix both.
Go spend 15 hours
researching on Google,
how to become better at YouTube.
And start realizing
you're on a marathon.
Take your sprinter shoes off.
- [Q] Yes.
Gary, I totally appreciate this.
- Go man. Good luck.
- He doesn't get,
like I'm 37 years old.
And I, like I said,
I started a few businesses
early on after reading books
that got me really motivational.
Like I was this young kid with
a global finance
degree and like I can do this.
But I kept my day
job for all these years.
And it wasn't until
this was finally the thing,
I never would
have thought it was
like cutting
stuff open on YouTube.
But that turned
out to be the thing
and now I can step away
from my day job and do this.
But sometimes
you gotta experiment
and be okay with
failing and walking away.
And going, I just
learned something better
than I could have
learned by spending
the money of getting an MBA.
Like I just
learned in the real world.
- Go figure.
Lincoln, the guests on this show
get to ask the
question of the day.
I would love for you to
ask the question of the day.
What question to you
want to ask the Vayner Nation?
By the way, it
could be anything.
It doesn't have to be
the theme of the show.
It doesn't have to,
it could literally be like,
what's your
favorite bubblegum flavor?
Like what are you
actually curious about
to get thousands
of people to respond
on Facebook and YouTube about?
- What is everyone's
favorite ice cream?
- Nice.
- That works with what
we've already talked about.
I like it.
- My man.
Thank you for being on the show.
- Yes.
- Thanks for having us.
- And you my man.
- Thanks you so much.
- You're awesome.
- Thanks for your advice.
- You keep asking questions,
we'll keep answering them.
(hip hop music)